[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link on this week's ear biscuit
where we gather around the round table
of dim lighting we talked to Julian
Smith talked to him about what it was
like growing up as a home schooler who
was also already a video professional by
the age of 15 how I got into YouTube and
we answer the 10 million dollar question
that's on all of your minds Julian Smith
where have you been why are you not
making comedy videos on YouTube anymore
well one of the things he's been doing
that we talked with him a little bit
about is he's been having a baby or at
least a woman that he impregnated had a
baby his wife he became a father I mean
just a number of weeks ago so that's
that I mean that's that's the big news
that's the first thing and you know in
being father's it's always I always
enjoy talking to somebody who is you
know it's just become a father they're
going through this milestone
you know I don't like to get too you
know advice laden and I want to be like
okay well here's what you got in store
in that kind of thing if they have
questions you know will answer them kind
of thing but you know it reminded me
that he leans going through this
milestone of becoming a father I feel
like I'm going through a very
significant milestone as a father and
that is really that my 9 year old lock
is now texting me
you gave him a cell phone did not give
him a cell phone now a lot of people be
controversial and I don't think he
should have a cell phone but maybe this
kind of slipped the cracks is what
happened is he has an iPod Touch well
you know what he has he has an an iPhone
3G that is just an iPod now because he
activated it doesn't have a SIM card in
it so it's essentially an iPod Touch he
can play games on and that kind of thing
well my kids also have those right but
we go back home my old phones that I
don't want anymore we go back home to
North Carolina for our friend Mike's
wedding over the weekend and you know my
wife and children stay for a few extra
days to kind of hang out with family and
that kind of thing well he finds out
from his cousin Isaiah that there is
this app that you can put on your phone
and using a Google account you can
essentially have an iPod touch
functions as a phone if you have a Wi-Fi
signal you can text you know basically
iMessage kind of thing but he can also
call so oh he can call you on a
telephone right but right but he can
only call like the few people that are
in the you know so he but he's texting
you mostly what are these texts well the
first texts I get from him yesterday is
it's me luck okay that's a good subject
so I know who that is
and then then he says I got this for you
and it's a there's a link and you click
on the link and it is a picture of a
king sized mr. Goodbar you like you like
those I do I do like them but that's
good he's thinking about you I think
this could be an added dimension to your
relationship but the problem is he can
also communicate with older females
that's what that's what you got to be
watching out for you got to limit who
he's gonna talk to well of course I'm
gonna do we talk older females well
because they have cellular telephones
really doesn't have their number like
the text but you don't know if he has it
they didn't even know he could
communicate via text until you got one
well that's true but then I call him I
call him on this number and the first
thing he says is he's like hey dad I'm
like and when i say older females i'm
sorry to interrupt
i'm just gonna come clean I'm talking
about my daughter here no I don't want
your son texting my daughter oh he's
okay yeah that's not gonna happen
they're just friends there's a good
friends one year apart so he I get him
on the phone after this because it can
clock and call this number that I've
been texted from and I can have a
conversation with him so the first thing
he says is he's like hey dad I'm like
hey like he's like hey I got you a
king-size mr. Goodbar yeah I got the
text so I mean that was important that a
redundant and I'm thinking okay how that
how's that thing gonna do on the plane I
don't know keep it out of the heat you
know I don't want melty mr. Goodbar but
then this morning at 8:55 a.m. I get
another text Taylor Swift just came out
with single sweeter than fiction this is
a nine year old so he's giving you
entertainment news yes so now he's
always on top of things but you know we
listen to music as a family we are
Taylor Swift fans the boys love to sing
her music and that kind of thing so so
we get the Taylor
with text but then right after that he
follows about where the text it says and
pleased by it
also by deaf punks new album it's a good
stuff I mean all this said week I'm
getting Daft Punk recommendations okay
about this uh it's a good album I own it
and so I agree with the lock you should
buy the album I mean it's a very trendy
thing to do the helmets and everything
that's very cool music it'll make you
cooler do you feel about my
nine-year-old texting me about mr. good
bars that's one thing but then texting
me about new albums that's pretty cool I
think it's proper usage of of the
appliance well so are you gonna get this
app for your kids so they can text you
never know I got to keep more control
over them but by that daft punk album
Lincoln music you're younger than luck
he listens to me play that one and it
has up all night to get lucky right
which is not necessarily a song that is
appropriate tell me I'm gambling for my
eight-year-old son to here until I hear
him singing it and I realized that he
thinks that lyrics are Mexican puppy
Mexican puppy upon sicken up up all
didn't even hear that up all night part
because it's when the robot starts
singing it just sounds like Mexican
puppy like like a chihuahua I'm yeah I'm
like you're singing about a chihuahua
okay so arm less you know so as long as
I'll tell like that's what it says
Mexican puppy okay well then I'll let my
kids text with him that no and then
we'll share all of this with Julian who
is a new father
alright let's get to our conversation
with Julian Smith he is a longtime
friend of ours so we had a great
conversation with gotten a lot of things
related to and proceeding to his YouTube
channel which you've want to check it
out if you don't know Julian Smith 87 he
is known for his incredibly cinematic
and credibly funny comedy sketches and
you've probably seen them even if you
don't know that you have because he's
got some videos out there with what 20
million views a Malc he put his cat in
an oven and waffles which hey we're
partial to that one because we might be
in that one may or may not be in that
one here it is our conversation with
Julian Smith
[Music]
okay so Julian you are fresh off of
having a baby I had a baby
yeah I didn't have the baby myself but
yes we're talking three weeks ago three
weeks this is one of the first things
I've done
are you don't look sleep-deprived this
baby is a freak of nature it sleeps
better than I can
after this you're still calling it you
don't know if it's a male or it's
surprise you heard of you heard of
people parents waiting to find out what
the gender is well put until it comes
into the world we're waiting until it's
18th birthday we're gonna shave its head
every week okay good good good never
look in the diaper without that's not
how you tell the sex of a child by the
length of the hair I'm just newsflash is
an indicator they're culturally that's
right no you have to look you have to
look at their private parts wait now you
haven't done that yet all right what
what's your child's name Nora
Eleonora we call her Nora Eleonora
middle name Eleanor Eleanor everybody's
calling her Eleanor I said Eleonora yeah
you said it right I'm just correcting
all the people that are in their cars
right now calling her Oh Eleanor hmm
Eleonora Lynn Lynn Smith Smith but she
goes by Nora yep she goes by Nora baby
with no age with no age you know all
right you know or II know is this an
eventful delivery anything exciting
happen did you faint serious everybody's
healthy now let's just listen I don't
know let's have a spoiler you you want a
spoiler yeah I need to know that Sarah's
okay the baby's okay is good baby's good
I assumed I would have heard that before
now well I gotta tell you I came here
because I knew it meant a lot to you but
really at home okay okay now I can
breathe easy you can just tell me the
the delivery process how does that work
I don't know how much you want to know
but all of it but Sarah's water actually
broke which is crazy because that only
happens like eight percent of the time
when your water breaks at home you guys
probably know that because you have
trying it happens 100% of time in the
movie in the movies happens all the time
because it's like the most exciting them
it could possibly happen but you know so
was this ahead of the due date or what
it was after the due date like three
days and three or four days yeah and so
her water broke at home and we hauled it
to the hospital and what were you doing
sleeping
oh she was asleep we were we were asleep
it was like 1:00 a.m. when her water
broke he's like 145 and she was like
Julian you've peed on the bed again yep
and you're like me this time I think we
need to get you but was it was it panic
was it it kind of was she she I was I
was like dead asleep and and I wake up
to honey I think my water just broke and
like within 13 minutes we were out the
door I remember looking at that's good
yeah so it's crazy and then traffic
traffic could be an issue in this town
so but not no not that or not that early
in the morning yeah that's a good thing
I got there and we when we we moved from
the valley to Venice mid pregnancy and
we decided to stay at the hospital that
we had in Tarzana because we liked our
doctor so much so we were oh well you
know it was a long drive but I got there
in 20 minutes that was the best possible
yeah you know timing yeah it was the go
in the middle at night cuz I could be
like a hour and a half drive you guys I
was going so fast on the 405 yes that is
the fastest I think anybody's going on
the 405 now was it was she like
screaming I mean was this how dramatic
was this she wasn't screaming but it was
definitely you know it was intense
neither it wasn't really knew what to
expect we haven't you know I've never
had a kid mm-hmm never been through that
process I was just get to the hospital
as fast as possible because especially
because her water had broken if it was
like mhm you know it was just labor you
know we would have had like five hours
to chill the house or whatever yeah and
you know so we were just we just knew we
had to get there the contractions were
were happening on the 405
you're like pedal to the metal yep I am
now there was a moment it be the boy I'm
kind of a crazy driver I'm a safe driver
I've never been in an accident that's my
fault okay and
and Sarah is always like you know she's
a she's a she's always telling me that I
need to chill out when I'm on the road
because I'm very aggressive you know on
the on the road and this was the one she
looked at me it was like this moment it
was like that moment in the movie where
she looks at me and she goes go fast and
I was like I can do that
baby's more I went fast and I got there
I got from I went from Venice to Tarzana
and 20 minutes that's that is close to a
record if not a record that has to be a
record seeing your wife in that much
pain I mean you know that okay in
principle that's gonna be part of it you
know that it's natural not necessarily
anything wrong is happening but it still
has to be a bit of anguish to see her go
through so much pain if you want to know
what someone would sound like is an
animal just get them pregnant really
brings that out it yeah so what animal
is Sarah a triceratops
well you said Triceratops no I'm not I'm
not into puns Rhett I know I demand that
you take me seriously right now okay
okay you feel different yeah it's like
you know they say you can't my dad
called me the week before
Nora came here and he said you don't
he's like you know the the kind of love
that you feel for this human being you
don't even have a slot for yet and it is
gonna blindside you and that's like
exactly how it is it's like a it's like
a totally different like I didn't even
know that this like sensation could
exist it's really strange for me anyway
it's probably different for everybody
but for me it was just it just I don't
love my kids so I mean like you were
very removed
you're only a few weeks into this thing
I you know I think there's something
that I've observed a lot of people are
still very new mom the mom there is this
instant connection because the previous
nine months right for the dad it's a
little different and I think I've heard
that it's it's common for the dad to
feel even a sense of guilt for not
feeling an instant connection yeah what
am i doing what it is it's definitely
different for me than it is for Sarah I
can tell that and you know and you know
I've had friends that have had kids and
they've like they've said that oh I had
to sit down my wife today and like you
know it's like they she thinks that I
don't like love this kid because you
know I it's not the same for me as it is
rehren and she has you know she's been
totally understanding like she doesn't
you know she totally gets it you know
and and you know it is different but I
still it still is like it hit me
immediately it was like this totally it
was like this rush of emotion that I
didn't when I was holding her for the
first time sorry I started like talking
about light now had no frame of
reference for what I was talking about
when I held Nora for the first time I
was like rush with these emotions and
you know I still everyday though it's
like I feel like I'm getting to know
this person you know and you can only
get to know someone so much when they
don't even speak English
oh yeah you'll start learning a lot when
Megan's trying to order a Taco Bell or
something
so was there was that bad should I have
not said that in the not gonna buy the
intercom the difficulties with the
intercom yeah is that is that is that
technologists pissed but that's it's
okay here we good good was there was it
traumatic at the point of delivery were
you like oh my gosh yeah it was crazy I
mean up to that point I thought like I
don't wanna when the baby's head starts
coming up that's when I look away and
that was like the moment where I shocked
myself I was like I can't stop watching
this this is amazing like I didn't I
didn't know I wasn't like weak at the
knees or anything
I thought it was gonna be but I wasn't
your father now you joined the club yeah
we can we can compare notes welcome on
this will tell you about all the
failures that we've had so far maybe you
can learn something and you know improve
I have no desire to learn but let's
let's go oh that's smart of you it's a
good mentality I found okay so I'm
assuming that you were born at some
point
I think so I'm still waiting to find out
I'm all about surprises and where was
that where are you from Nashville
Tennessee now you've got a slew of
siblings mm-hmm and the second oldest of
six second oldest you got older brother
sister older sister okay she has six
kids she's pregnant with her sixth right
now
crazy I got a lot of work to do the
pressures just kidding I'm not doing
that
you don't aspire to that okay you got an
older sister and then let's see
so that leaves four younger than you did
I just do that right I think so yeah six
of you total yeah okay so so what six
kids in this day and age just a lot of
kids what's the dynamic here growing up
dad do what your mom did so when I was
really young my dad was a he was an
executive at a record label he worked he
actually he he worked you know he had a
pretty long music career in Nashville
doing like country and Christian music
kind of I mean that's pretty much the
only market there I think it may be
growing a little bit now but we've got
um back in the 80's and 90's that's
pretty much all there was so he was he
was pretty influential influential yep
is all they're even better than
influential that's my southern coming
out adding syllables now he was he was
he had a pretty long career in music and
my mom is a what as an executive like
doing a tower finding bands signing them
and and what does he have like a claim
to fame and my dad is those modest
person yeah I don't I I still I get the
feeling that I don't really know
everything he's done but like every
three years I hear like the two years
ago I found out that he that he is
responsible for Garth Brooks cutting the
dance what and I was like what I know
about this it apparently like Garth
Brooks came into my dad's office like as
a nobody and was like like playing colds
like cold playing songs for like record
labels along a no-name guy and
and no he wasn't no name maybe he had it
was before the dance so I'm not super
familiar with Garth Brooks or what his
you know yeah that was on his first like
this breakout okay I got me pause you
for a second now Rhett can you sing some
of the dance
do you remember it looking back on
memories of dance we shared he loved us
alpha means no stars above it sounds
like it take it in that you'd ever say
goodbye and now I don't know how long I
just can't stop looking at him Clojure
it looks like it hurt how does the
course the way it all would Ian way it
all would go I can only imagine Garth
Brooks sitting in your dad's office
I remember Dan even know the song that's
what that's how good of a son I am I
never even listened to it to that song
in the Rua 10 building my let's see
ninth grade Melissa somebody was in 10th
grade and she wanted to dance with me
after I broke up with Tabitha and that
was the dance that we danced to wow that
was a good song but that was the song
that I think established Garth Brooks
yeah on the scene yeah I knew that my
your dad can yeah so apparently
apparently my dad was pushing for Garth
Brooks to do that song and nobody wanted
to let him do it they were like didn't
believe in the song I didn't think it
sounded right and my dad was like
pushing from the beginning like I didn't
do it and my dad was like one of the key
people that ended up like pushing the I
don't know what the expression I should
which expression I should use here but
he was the one that ended up like well
only one guy can do a song so once that
song is paired with somebody in country
music other people can do it later but I
mean in modern country music that does
it doesn't happen that often a song goes
with a guy and that's his you know let's
see there's ticket it either works or it
doesn't
right it's my understanding yeah so
that's pretty big deal yeah so I'm
always finding stuff out about my dad
I'm like gonna find out one day that
he was actually like a secret agent and
I never really knew his real name so he
was he was dabbling in country music and
Christian music he was doing the Toby
Keith in the TobyMac type situation
yeah actually yeah Toby Mack - he did
some stuff with DC talk okay uh-huh yeah
and you were born in 87 87 because
that's your username on YouTube yeah
let's not let's not talk about that so
user name I got stuck with it okay so
this is I guess this is around that same
time so he was working in that business
when you were before you were born and
then even through that yeah what about
your mom my mom is a published author
and playwright and she my earliest
memories of her was I have a lot of
memories of her directing dinner
theaters and things like that so she you
know my parents definitely both
influenced me a lot you know I grew up
in a really creative house all of us
pretty much all of us play an instrument
and do something with the right part of
our brains they told you to get guitar
lessons is that what happened yeah I've
actually never had a guitar lesson my
dad taught me some basics as a kid but I
was never really good at a like
classroom setting it's like half that's
like a major reason that I was
home-schooled for the large part of my
life
we're all your siblings homeschooled
yeah after I was in I went I was in
elementary school until third grade and
then my parents pulled me and the rest
of my siblings but one of the one of the
big reasons was because my kindergarten
teacher thought I was autistic told you
guys about this no I don't think so
might like based on I guess at the time
they were really big on analyzing like
drawings that the kids were doing and
based on my drawings like my like the
facial features of the people I would
draw were out of place like they would
have noses for ears and like ears for
eyes and things like that was really
wacky drawings and they had a few
meetings with my parents they were
really worried about Julian and like my
parents were like he's just he's just
weird he's not autistic he's just weird
do you think your noses are funny yeah
yeah basically I made a personal I'm not
being to talk totally fair I was a
little bit I don't think I was a problem
child but I definitely like pushed my
teachers a little bit like I was I would
find out that they were having a fire
drill you know do you guys remember fire
you
so I'd find out that there was going to
be a fire drill happening and I would
tie my shoelaces to the chair so that
when the bell went off like I'd just be
like sitting in my chair and like the
teachers would be like what are you
doing I can't get up and like they'd
have to help me untie my double knotted
laces from the chair and that'd be like
the last one out of the classroom so I
think that I think there was some of
that too I think they were kind of like
he's just the things that he thinks of
are not good and now in third grade they
took you out yeah they said we'll do the
homeschool thing
yeah your sister they they took her out
your older sister out and then my
younger brother who what he wasn't even
in school at the time so all the rest of
my siblings were and still are some of
them are still homeschooled so actually
only one of them is still in school so
you had this okay
to creative parents mmm-hmm you got six
kids being homeschooled so did you guys
do like family productions is it one of
those situations like where they were
like you know let's let's sing together
let's do this play together and while
wearing gene jumpers my we try to do
some of that but it didn't really work
out I guess I don't know so I mean some
things would work like my mom would put
us in some of her dinner theater things
like doing like live drama and like that
you know we did that setting worked but
like I remember she also tried to get us
to do like a family band at one point
and that just went terribly like I
didn't even think there was anything
south of Nashville until I realized you
could go further down that did not work
you mean on tour no I just mean it was
so bad oh I realized that word yeah baby
I'm now and now I am doing the puns look
at me I mean that I definitely I wanted
to hear that you guys like put out an
album because when I hear about a really
creative family with all these children
I just you know it's like daddy sang
bass mama sang treble one think that's
what my mom was hoping for naturally you
don't seek trouble mama sing the tweeter
okay but I didn't happen didn't happen
now so did you fit the stereotypical
homeschool upbringing and you know I
will say you know this we homeschool our
kids
yeah and ret and that's why Jesse home
schools their kids so that was a big
factor in us making a decision was the
was the stigma in the stereotype you
talk about the gene jumpers yeah and the
ultra ultra strict and ice sheltered and
I guess is the word I'm looking for
what was your experience growing up
homeschooled it was it a sheltered type
of a thing I would say was sheltered you
know it was actually it was really great
for me because I knew from a very early
age what I you know what I wanted to I
knew I wanted to be in either music or
film like very early and so I was in
high school I mean now I'm skipping a
little bit but in high school I my
friends and I would shoot little like
home videos on the weekends was for fun
and then that eventually turned into me
you know freelancing editing for other
people and so I was like and I was like
15 16 and I was doing my school at night
so that I could do these like day jobs
for like I was like getting clients and
stuff like that so home schooling was
great for me for that reason so you're
you so you did have friends yeah you
weren't your friends weren't just your
family members oh you want to talk about
friends you had friends see I'm still
trying to figure out what these are no
I'm kidding no I I think that the secret
to home I think that a lot of parents
want to they think like okay so we're
gonna homeschool our kids we got to make
sure that they're social so we got to
get all these home schoolers together a
talk and I think that's like the like
that's okay but that can't be their only
social interaction because like I don't
know how it is today but when I was in
elementary school I would go to these
homeschool get-togethers like I remember
one very vividly that was at a roller
skating rink every week oh yeah so
terrible it was like I was like seven no
no yeah no I was probably like eight or
nine don't even understand what it means
to be like good or bad at a social
setting
I'm like this is awkward they didn't
have a cookie cake I don't remember
anything like that I just remember like
leaving every conversation with every
kid feeling very dissatisfied and
confused and like it just didn't it
seemed very like weird and it was weird
and so I just I didn't like going to
those things and you know there was a
homeschool prom and I was like I'm
definitely not going to that you don't
be called good at that thing yeah so I I
just think that those things aren't
quite the answer I think you got to find
you got to get your kids involved in
something else and so I wasn't how does
youth find real friends at like a nine
year old that's a good age I was really
involved with my church at the time so I
had a lot of friends involved I had a
lot of friends through my church but I
also was like I don't know I was just
most of my friends were through like I
was just like a I was like a social
virus I would just like find if somebody
that I liked and then I would just like
force my way into their life in
hindsight it's kind of weird I would
just like meet all their friends and so
I actually ended up I didn't go to my
own prom but I would go to I went to
like five of my friends proms and like I
would so I had all these different like
groups of friends and none of them
really knew each other but I would I
don't know I got around there was
pressure I was like I was I was like I
was like a friend a friend prostitute
now your dad at some point didn't he
switch to be like a pastor of your
church Yeah right
he left the music industry when I was
around 11 or 12 and my both my parents
are very entrepreneurial and he you know
tried he started a few different
ventures on it on his own and he still
got a few of those going and then
somewhere along the way what an inventor
know like music stuff like doing music
on his own you know I think he just got
tired of being a part of like the big
label industry and it was so I don't
know I mean everybody knows what I mean
when I say that it he just wanted to be
like a lone ranger like doing his thing
and you know so he's kind of done that
over the years and he's done a you know
he's the guy can do everything so he's
done a plethora of things over the
decades including pastor a church yeah
and he started pastoring a church about
gosh I didn't know how long it's been
eight to ten years ago something like
that did not yeah eight years ago
probably is around oh four or something
like that yeah so about ten years okay
so I mean you you were kind of
transitioning into adulthood yeah and I
actually in the early stages of that I
was I was around 17 or 18 and I had
found this job I was like I was out of
high school and I my parents were like
okay you're either gonna go to college
or you're gonna find a way to make money
doing this video stuff that you know
you're passionate about and so it sounds
like you had been doing for a couple of
years yeah they said you were fifteen or
sixteen and you had clients yeah I mean
I was I was you know I was doing more
than the average like fifteen or sixteen
year-old was like work-wise but a what I
wasn't like going and looking for
apartments you know so they were like
you either got to turn this into
something stable are you gonna go to
school and you know learn how to make a
stable so when I graduated high school I
went on monster.com which I don't even
know if that's still around anymore is
it
and I started looking for jobs in the
area and one thing that came up was a
there was this there's this mega church
in Nashville called at the time it was
called Bellevue Community Church and
they were looking for a full-time video
guy and I was like I'm gonna try out for
that did the monster listing say Mecca
Church yes I just say that because it's
like when you say a church way okay good
sure it's like like what what when when
you usually say Church people picture
like pews and like 50 people and it's
like so when you say video guy at a
place like that it's like what kind of
what are you possibly making you know
and maybe as a point of clarification
for people who may not you know being in
the south and even being in Nashville
yeah I mean we have what we would call
mega churches where we come from you
know being in the Bible Belt you've got
these massive commune for all the
majority of people go to church and then
you've got these massive churches with
thousands of people and then in
Nashville I know it's so I mean there's
we don't see much of that even even out
here in California right it's very
different it's a very big part of the
culture there in Nashville so it's just
like that's what those of you listening
that's what a mega church is it's not
like a church that's about to take over
the world it's just a very large Church
it's basically a giant business that is
like that
well the coffee shop yeah yeah they have
a coffee shop they have like a staff of
a creative team we have an audio guy
they have like all it's like a it's like
a mini production house they like we had
this church that I went on to work for
they had like they had their ol like
creative offices that was disconnected
from the church and it was like we
worked on a creative staff there and it
was that was like where I learned the
bulk of you know what I've learned today
there's just you know I got to you're
talking about the job you took the job I
took the job was the position a video
director well tell us how we got to
YouTube let me rephrase that I know how
I got to YouTube how you got to you tell
I got to YouTube yeah well I I just when
YouTube came out and things were
starting to kind of go viral on there I
was like well heck I've got hundreds of
these videos I've shot my friends I
could put a couple up there and see what
happened and so I started putting a
couple of my favorites up there and and
it was like really unofficial it wasn't
even like I wasn't even trying anything
I was just like I'll put him on YouTube
so I can send them to my friends easier
and stuff like that and then I went in
any videos that we that are still up
that we we would know I think there's a
couple there's actually yeah there's one
called keV it's an awkward I did it I
had a series of videos that I did called
awkward moments and one of them called
Kevin's bro is still up I think I think
it's the first video I uploaded okay
I had uploaded several before that
they're now unlisted but that's the that
one is like before I was actually trying
anything legitimately that was just like
me and friends goofing off right not
trying anything okay so that's still on
there I think but I remember I went
through a I went through a pretty
serious breakup I was with this girl for
like three years and this was in
Nashville and and I wanted to get out of
Nashville let me guess
the megachurch pastors daughter no I
wasn't that southern okay yeah no but uh
and I decided to go move to Buffalo New
York with my best my best friend Lou
that's quite a breakup okay you're with
this girl
well we it was pretty it was pretty
serious relationship we were like you
know
in the shop aged no but pretty close to
it we're pretty close to it I mean in
the South you guys hide is it's like
you're a teen star thing about marriage
so there's that kind of so with a high
school home school high school
sweetheart type thing yeah yeah well she
wasn't homeschooled she was in a real
school she was in a real school I heard
her problems one of the ones I actually
went to so though no very notable but
anyways we broke up and I was like well
I kind of want to just get out of this I
had been kind of wanting to look for
something this is right when the partner
program had been introduced and I'd kind
of heard about it on YouTube and I was
like well maybe I could try to do some
like weekly videos and see what happens
you know
and so we broke up and I moved to
Buffalo with my to live with my best
friend who was up there and and I just I
shot this series guy I want to know your
frame of mind now
so forgive me for digging on and so
forth were you was this like heartbroken
situation I just leave the state yeah
this was like I don't want to do her I
dumped her but it was like it was really
hard like I still really cared about her
but like I knew it wasn't gonna work
because we had we were just too
different and like I knew that if we got
married I'd be really I'd be a really
unhappy 40 year old one day so I just
I'd called it off it was really hard
I actually I did it the worst way to I
wrote her a letter oh no Julie I wrote
her a letter I was such a - more than a
text though yeah I mean we talked we
talked after that
how long was the letter it was a long
sentence it was like a three-page letter
it was really we were I mean it was a
really hard thing it wasn't like you
know it was a pretty intense thing and I
could have handled it better in
hindsight but I was like I didn't know I
didn't know anything so he wrote a
three-page letter than you went to
Buffalo yeah went to Buffalo and I just
had a phone conversation with her after
we talked a bunch we actually almost got
back together
who glad that didn't know really yeah
that always happens that after you moved
to Buffalo or but yeah after we after I
moved to Buffalo I rolled up there it is
cold up there meaning that's what makes
you want to go back to Nashville and be
with the work the work
look at me like that I was like why are
you talking about the weather I'm with
you rat don't worry yeah you can get it
so I'm up there and I'm like I'm just
gonna dig my head in the ground and try
to focus on you know making little funny
videos and releasing them and I was up
there and a friend of my my friend Mark
the guy that I moved up there with his
friend Chris Porsche came over one day
and introduced us and Chris was like a
very quiet like reserved person he's
like a he's a he's a scientist he's like
one of these people that's actually a
scientist for a living and and so he was
like very quiet at first but he started
kind of warming up and I was like this
guy's actually after a couple days of
hanging out there like this guy's
actually kind of funny and so I asked
him I was like if I could think of
something to shoot with you would you
want to be in it and he was like you
know kind of taken aback I could tell
because he had never heard that question
before he's like yeah sure I guess and
so I had this idea to shoot a series
where I get kidnapped and I'm not gonna
I'm gonna get killed if I don't meet a
certain amount of subscribers so this
guy Chris Porsche ended up being like
the guy that is now called Gabrielle on
the kidnap series and so we shot that
and I met my deadline and I shot a bunch
of other videos while I was up there a
deadline of subscribe subscribers yeah
what was your goal I think it was a
thousand subscribers and five weeks of
thousand subscribers yeah okay something
like that so I got there and then I
moved back to Nashville I moved back to
Nashville and just kept making videos I
did that for and I still hadn't gotten
partnered yet this was still like you
know I moved back home and I was like
living with my parents and they were
like what are you doing what is this
YouTube nonsense you know and they were
very supportive of my end goal you know
which I wanted to make movies one day
but I think they weren't they just
weren't as familiar with the framework
as I was and how you are you making a
living at this at this point I had saved
up a bunch of money from freelancing
cousin making pretty good money at the
time so I just saved up a chunk of money
so I could live off of for a while so I
was taking like I took like several
months off and just was focusing on this
okay so I after moving back to Nashville
from Buffalo it was this was like when I
I had I had met my kidnapped goal of
subscribers like okay maybe I can do
this maybe I can like do this enough to
where I could get like partnered and
start getting a little bit of money from
this and so within like four months of
that I shot this video called I see was
it four months it was like yeah is like
four or five months later I shot this
video called twenty five things I hate
about Facebook and this was back when
YouTube actually featured stuff on the
home page and they featured it right and
it was like overnight like my channel
just blew up like that we were shooting
another we were shooting a video I was
shooting video with like ten of my
friends at my parents house when a
friend of mine text me was like you're
on the front page of YouTube right now
and I had this moment where I had like
the camera on we were about to shoot
some we were about to shoot this take
and I like froze for a second and I was
like wait a minute I was like really and
like everything stopped for a second and
I checked my email and this is when I
had all my notifications going to my
email and I had like 3,000 emails or
something like that and I was like I
better turn these off so I turned those
off and you know like overnight like I
got partnered like like almost
immediately it was like two days later I
got partnered and I was able to start
generating a little bit of money off of
my channel and my my parents were kind
of like at that point they're like okay
I could see how this could work but I
still wasn't I still wasn't full-time
doing that until like a year later or
something like that so you're still
doing the freelance yeah I was still
freelancing a little bit and doing
YouTube on the side so connect the dots
from the Facebook video to getting
partnered to then getting on the
television show smash cuts yeah yes so I
was still living in Nashville but I was
traveling out to LA about once a month
twice a month and I was doing this a lot
for just general roles and stuff like
that and auditions I had an agent out
here but it wasn't like making enough
money to justify moving out here yet so
my agent you know and I had met Sara I
met Sara on one of these trips and we
immediately started dating and I was
like this girl's awesome we were making
me her she actually I hate telling the
story she wrote she was working for a
blog at the time and she was like
writing an entertainment column and she
wrote about 25 things I hate about
Facebook and her company wanted to meet
me since I was out here for all these
generals so I came out her company
meaning the blog
she wanted to meet right know is
actually her company social vibe was
they they had all these like they worked
with a bunch of different youtubers at
the time and like doing like I guess
endorsements or I cannot know what the
what the scenario was but yeah they they
said if you're gonna be out in LA we'd
like to meet you and Sarah had sent me a
message on Facebook I think it was
because at the time I didn't have a I
don't think they had fan pages yet so I
just had a personal profile like 5,000
friends or something like that and she
had added me in case I made anything
else new so she sent me a message and I
saw her picture and I was like so
basically from your perspective of fans
sends you a Facebook message yeah and
you're trolling your old Facebook
messages for good-looking girls yeah
basically no shame in that yes we
started dating and I was back and forth
between Nashville in LA for several
months and so she interviews you for the
blog and then it turns into a date well
no we actually I had seen her picture
from that Facebook message I remember
that so I she and I started I was like I
should get your number so that I know
how to you know a slightly got her
number and we stepped out of what call
you you I said so I know how to whatever
I know so I I don't know why how I got
her number but I was like we should just
it was like I think it was I think it
was clear why I wanted her number but I
made it seem like it was business yeah
and so we started texting and and then
like I found out she had a really good
sense of humor and so then we started
like talking on the phones before we had
ever met so when I'm when I came out to
LA for those generals the night I got
there I took her out to dinner so like
it was like before I even had the
meeting with her company I was like
taking her out and getting to know her
that's good that's oh no so then we were
long-distance for a while when I was
back and forth between these two places
Nashville in LA and my agents called me
and they were like hey we have this
there's this show that we want you to
audition for when you're out here next
month and so maybe just bring like a
bigger suitcase in case you end up
getting it because it would start
immediately so I didn't tell Sarah
because I didn't want her to like get
her hopes up said I was gonna be moving
out there but I just packed like a big
suitcase
and came out is actually a crazy story I
had like 40 dollars in my bank account
when I came out for this trip I couldn't
even afford a rental car Sarah didn't
know any of this
she just still doesn't know any of this
no I'm kidding so I was I was staying at
some at a friend's house who was out of
the country I was using his car and and
that's how I was like getting by out
here with no money and I'm gonna saw
dition and and I'm like I don't think
that audition went very well I've never
been good at auditions so I walk out and
my my car got towed my friend's car got
towed and he's out of the country I have
no way of getting in touch with him so
I'm like how do I get home how do I get
this car how do I pay for the car if I
can even like prove that I know the guy
who it belongs to and so I called my dad
and I'm like dad can I borrow some money
if I can prove that I'm and responsible
for this car while my friends head up
the country and so my dad wires me some
money because they're gonna demand cash
right right and like probably $250 at
least yeah so my dad's my dad wires me
some money I I can't remember how but
somehow through a freak of nature I
guess it was my social virus coming out
again I prove that I'm connected to this
guy and I get the car back it was he was
around he was like that same day I get
the call my agent called me and they're
like by the way you got the gig on the
show and I was like oh my gosh like that
is amazing cuz I don't know like how I
was gonna eat next week
you know like right so so what was the
audition it was basically an improv
audition and I it was like I remember it
it was like they just threw a bunch of
curveballs at us they were like okay so
we did the game The Improv game where
you one person likes as a sentence and
the other person says the sentence and
you have to tell a story and like it's
one sentence at a time and they just
like switch it at random and then I did
another actually the it's funny because
I I still tell Donovan Jordan the guy
that's in a bunch of my videos I I still
tell him he's responsible for all this
mess because he was he had already
gotten he was already cast on the show
and he was in one of the auditions I had
to do one of the game improv games I had
to play
and I was yo I was in I was auditioning
against this one other guy that was up
for the same role as I was and I guess I
did such a mediocre job in the audition
that the executives of the show I didn't
know which guy they wanted to hire so me
and the guy walk out of the room and
they they oh you were both there head to
head no we were taking turns with
Donovan oh wow and and Donovan broke my
sunglasses in the in the during the
improv game it was intense so he felt
bad for me and told them that they
should hire me that's how I got the kick
Donovan Jordan I guess and so okay and
and I can kind of tell this a little bit
from our perspective because you ended
up well you haven't said what the show
eating on the show smash cuts yeah which
was a clip show that talked about viral
videos right and with four hosts which
incidentally some of you might know that
in 2007 we were on a show called online
nation on the same network right on CW
that was about viral videos that had
four hosts in our in it's a very it's a
very successful network well we're
trying a lot of things now the
interesting thing is is that as I know
that you know we have our own set of
embarrassments related to our job with
all nine nation and a note that you have
your own set of embarrassments with
smash cuts but from our perspective when
I saw the show we were like okay well
this is a lot better than what we were
involved with that was the first thing I
thought and then I was like you know
what and my four-year-old son really
likes this show he he when the first
time we ever met you
he was like I'm meeting Julian from
smash cuts he absolutely loved the show
that's funny
so anyway so yeah so same show we we had
the same position only difference is two
years later and yours went a little
longer and somehow was syndicated it was
like a season but then they kept
replaying it when it got renewed but
it's actually the long the long short of
it is that the show lost a lot of money
in development because there was
originally like eight
seven or eight hosts and like CBS there
was a huge miscommunication when they
sold the show CBS thought they were
buying a sketch comedy show and then
they like I don't know how they have
this happened but like they got we shot
like four episodes and like commercials
for the show and everything and then
they CBS finally decided hey maybe we
should watch this and because CBS like I
guess so you shot four episodes of a
sketch show yeah yeah and they were
including some of my sketches from my
youtube channel in the mix and I was
like really excited about this so men
CBS sees it and then they're like oh
well we thought we were buying a clip
show and so then they send all these
executives to set and there's like two
weeks where they're eliminating hosts
and nobody knows who's getting fired
next really survivor yeah and and so
like I was thinking like man if I lose
this gig like I don't know I have to
move back home I'm gonna tell Sarah like
I have to move away again because I
can't support myself off what I'm making
from YouTube and I had this apartment
that I'd signed the year lease on it was
kind of expensive and like I didn't know
what I was gonna do so I fortunately
didn't get cut but they lost so michaux
lost so much money in development that
the only way they could make their money
back was if they the show got renewed
and they didn't reshoot anything and
they just kind of repackaged it and
mixed the episodes mixed the footage up
so it looked like they were unique
episodes but it was actually made up of
non unique footage and smart and they
didn't have to pay their hosts royalties
because it was a quote-unquote reality
show so we all had these lousy reality
show contracts and I didn't see a dime
for any of that syndication
oh well terrible now our old problems it
was at least much more of a perceived
success your show was an hour's hour we
shot eight episodes and they aired four
oh really they aired four and I remember
we would we didn't live here in LA for
that of course they would they would fly
us out for like a week and we would
shoot three episodes or so because I
know we flew out three different times
in the third time we flew out we were
shooting when it was our time we flew
out that we we thought we were coming
out to shoot the the next four episodes
but the show got canceled before we came
but we had already bought the tickets
and so that was when I came out for
meetings so trips no trips with the four
episodes
the last the last one that we filmed
they had already started to air and the
show wasn't good and we were shooting
The Last Stand as I stand ups tossing to
the to the videos before we fly back and
we turned to our to co-host Stevie Ryan
and joy Leslie Stevie Ryan has a show on
vh1 now oh wow yeah
sketch show we turn to them and as we
said the last times you said all right
Stevie and joy it was great knowing you
that's how they told you this is it no
that's how we we know like we knew that
the show we had announced that it was
that it was gonna be canned
we just knew it because we had seen the
show on television we turn to Stevie and
join really all right great knowing you
that was great there was like what oh my
god yeah haven't you watched the show
ain't gonna continue the same way about
smash cuts every episode i watch I I
eventually stopped watching it I was
like this is gonna get canned and I
don't want to know when it's coming I
just I only watched like four episodes
because you're basically just doing a
Bob Saget I mean yeah I've had some fun
with it and you had some other things
that weren't just America's Funniest
Home Videos trying to be modernized but
it's really just pretending to try to
make Internet videos relevant on
television and it just was admit it just
was a miss yeah yeah after after smash
cuts rapped I'd say like two or three
months afterwards I was full time
YouTube and I signed it maker at the
time somewhere around there and then
yeah and that was like when I signed it
maker that was around the time where I
went full-time because I remember them
saying they were talking about my
strategy and they were like if you keep
this up you know next month you'll be
there you know you won't be doing
freelance anymore and I was like great
so I remember that I remember that day
where I got that where I got the news
that I was like where I realized I was
gonna be able to do this full-time and
it was like I was sitting in my car and
I was just like so thankful it's a I'll
never forget that day
yeah well I mean as as people who were
friends of yours and I definitely fans
you know our perspective and I think we
probably speak on behalf of a lot of
people who are fans of yours you know we
were like this guy's doing things that
are I mean you know incredibly funny
also incredibly slick you know like
everyone everyone talks about okay well
if Julian Smith does it it's going to
look incredible it's going to look like
a movie you know lots of people the the
production level on YouTube has risen
across the board in a lot of ways but
you were doing that and still do it
better but we're doing it a lot better
than a lot of other people at the time
and so there was this like when Julian
does something he does it right and like
what do you think it is about you your
personality your approach to things like
what is your perspective hearing that
from us that that's how we would
perceive your content is like oh yeah we
might make something that's really funny
and it might look pretty good but then
Julian does something it's like man this
is like an this is on another level
what's your perception of yourself and
your content in that way I just got
really tight I mean I didn't making
videos for so long and I got you know I
started making videos and I was like
twelve and I was very I became very
familiar very fast with like every year
I would look back on the videos I did
the year before and I'd be like ashamed
of how it looked and how it sounded and
like because I was learning so much and
I was I just got to a place when I
started freelancing where I was really
tired of not liking things that I made
like three years later and I really
enjoy liking things years after I make
them and so I think that's probably why
I think it's so valuable to put all that
time into it because it does it doesn't
really make a whole lot of sense
monetarily I could make a whole lot more
money if I just didn't care about that
part of it and that you know just like
you know hired 16 year old to come shoot
it or something like that you know
actually I could do a lot I could make a
lot more content is what I'm saying
you know yeah but I I would much rather
look back like you know I'm really happy
with what's on my channel right now and
I I wouldn't trade that for anything you
know I want to get to your music and and
where you're at with that and how that
was how your audience perceives where
you're at right now having done the
music but before we get there
I also wanted to touch base on the
amount of videos on your on your channel
started to dwindle a little bit more and
you were producing equals 3 yeah ray
william johnson and
so how did how did that start happening
in terms of what strategy for you you
know when I heard that I was like okay I
didn't think so
are you producer now production company
what you have produced are the goth boy
video - yeah yeah that was right around
the time you were like well I'm gonna
I'm gonna you know I want to make my own
stuff but I want to produce other people
stuff we're like hey we got this project
and so we collaborated on that so yeah
kind of what led to that sort of change
in strategy I didn't like intentionally
stop making videos I mean I was
definitely gonna slow down and try some
new things you know that I'd been
wanting to try for a while I've known
for years that I wanted I've always
wanted to make an EP and essentially I
still want to make a full-length album
one day you know these are you know I
wanted there's a lot of things I want to
try I loved at all but you know I the I
never intended to not make anything in
2013 right it was just kind of how it
happened you know so you know I
definitely knew that but you did make a
choice I'm gonna work on music I'm gonna
do the production thing but then I'm
going to make it a priority to work on
music and it's not good you know from
from our experience when you told us I'm
focusing on music okay so like funny
songs like more of the same but just
more songs and you're like I remember
you looked very disoriented when I told
you I was just I was just role-playing
what your audience would think right
right kind of no but you did make a
strategic decision to focus on music and
instead of your sketches well you know I
was writing a movie I was writing a
movie at the beginning of 2013 that I
thought was going to be you know I've
written a million not a million
different like three movie screenplays
that I thought was gonna be my first
movie and then I decided later I don't
want to do that when I'm gonna I can do
better than that you know I want to push
myself a little harder so I was writing
a movie at the time that I knew I I
wanted to make and I knew I was really
getting stressed out with figuring out
what next to do comedy wise on YouTube
because I had done so many different
kinds of things and I didn't want to
just like repeat where I had been you
know and I can tell I can tell I could
tell from some of the stuff I was
releasing my audience
like you know like you said they're like
where's the next mark you know and it's
like you know I don't want to be the guy
that just releases stuff because like
there's people there waiting on it
that's not how I look at my channel like
I said I look at it as like a way to
exercise a muscle and so if I'm not
pushing harder than I have in the past
then I don't want to do anything you
know so that's how I was looking at it
and so yeah there was a while there was
a few months early on in the year where
I was like yeah maybe maybe I'm done
with YouTube maybe I'm just not cut out
for this because it seems like there are
so many other people in my life that are
doing it that are like you guys have
been doing it for so long and I have no
idea like where you muster it up like I
just you're so good at it and like you
you keep coming up with stuff that seems
fresh and I just I you know I I want I
think I I think a part of me was like I
want to focus on this movie because I
know I could I know I can make a movie
one day and maybe I need to find
something that I can maybe I need to
just experiment a little bit so I can
buy myself some time to work on this
movie and so I was like well I've always
wanted to make an EP and I'm and I had
been also writing a lot at the time like
a you know I've always written music in
my spare time but at the time I was
writing a lot and I was like well maybe
I'll just make an EP or at the time I
was thinking it might be a full-length
album but it ended up being an EP so
yeah there was a few months where I
wasn't sure what was gonna have him with
my YouTube channel but I never you know
intended to like shut it down or
anything like that or like but when you
were focusing on music you said okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna make an album of X
number of songs they're gonna it's gonna
be a sincere album it's not like it's
gonna be a comedy album but but you you
knew that you had to know that people
would expect okay he if he's not gonna
do YouTube at least he's gonna give me
something that's comparable to what he's
been giving me it's you know how much of
those thoughts entered your mind because
you certainly paint a picture as as an
artist who is you have an internal
standard and it's a very loud voice that
you that you follow that you know for us
maybe we follow our fans to a fault but
was there a concern there of what they
were going to think I mean across my
mind I knew people were gonna lie
when I announced that there was gonna be
an album I knew people were gonna
immediately think it was gonna be comedy
but that wasn't a concern of mine I you
know I I I don't know I just I just do
things I want to do well is it okay you
know is it frustrating though is it
frustrating to because you because I
mean you know you actually you let us
see the the music video before it came
out
yeah gave us a little preview and we
were like this is awesome yeah you know
we expected no less of how great of a
song it is and how great of a music
video it is and and then I and I look at
some of the comments and of course
there's there are perceptive fans and I
think it was there was a very positive
response mm-hm
overall but you still have those people
who are like you know so when is that
you know when is that next thing that
you like what you used to write you
there was a lot of zero so confuse
people they didn't really know I think
it kind of came out of left field for
some people and you know I guess I guess
I am very I am very that my fans are a
factor absolutely in in what I do and
you know I definitely think that you
know I owe a lot to them because they
you know they've enabled me to keep
making things you know so but at the
same time you know the way I look at my
channel is so strange because I've
always looked at it is not a I don't
look at it as like an enterprise or like
like it's not a it's not really a
business to me even it's it's it's just
a place where I get to put things that I
make you know I get to post them there
and they get yeah and that's how it
started and when I mean that's Russian
the channel name is Julian Smith 87 so
it wasn't clearly started with any
intent of it's an expression of who you
are as an artist I think is what I'm
hearing you say yeah not is that a place
to fulfill expectations right and yeah
yeah I've never there's never really
been there's but there was like there
was like one year where there was
consistency in my channel where like
there was a day you could come and they
would be something new I did that for a
year and then I realized like that's not
like I'm not gonna be able to keep this
up and so ever since then you know I've
you could come to expect a certain
but like there's never really been
consistency on my channel in every
capacity you know right it's never been
like a TV station or anything like that
were you can tune in and like you know
even when it was all comedy like you
never really knew what if it was gonna
be like a like like which character was
gonna be or which song it was gonna be a
song I didn't even know I was flying by
the seat of my pants you know so it's
like I don't know I guess it's yeah I
guess I guess I just don't really I
don't have any plans with it what so
what would you say to your fans who are
listening this is what they've been
waiting for for you to tell them when
you're coming back and how you're coming
back that's their perspective what would
you say to them I will say I you know
haven't having taken the year to reflect
and take some time off I have you know I
have a very clear understanding now of
where I want to go and what I want to do
and I actually am writing my movie now
that will definitely be my first movie
I'm going to try to shoot it and if next
year and in the meantime I am going to
pick back up on my YouTube channel and
keep things going it will probably look
a little different than it has in the
past
it'll still be comedy it'll probably be
a lot of different things that would
probably still be as inconsistent as it
always has been
but I'm not going anywhere I still
really care about that channel I still
really love that channel I love having
that outlet to be able to express myself
and I'm so thankful to have that that
place and the people that have come to
enabled me to be able to make those
things so I'm not gonna abandon any of
that I will be continuing to make things
I don't know exactly how soon but I will
say soon I will say definitely before
the end of the year there will be
regular content on the channel
okay well I think people will be happy
to hear that and i and i think that i
mean and and most likely sooner if i
didn't want to do youtube anymore I
wouldn't do youtube anymore I didn't
hardly do it at all this year and
you know and I I've made money other
ways you know it was so that is there if
I come back it will not be it's because
I need to make ends meet because I don't
I am not capable of creating on the
basis of making ends meet I wish I could
but I cannot operate under that pressure
it has to be something I want to do so I
think in a lot of ways that's why I
started my production company which I'll
continue to keep alive and grow you know
I will funnel all of my productions
through the production company you know
and I still have a lot of plans for it
but I think that's why I initially
started it because I was like well maybe
there's other ways I can maybe I don't
have to do as much YouTube content and I
can make a living other ways and I don't
have to have the pressure of making
something that I don't really
necessarily want to make you know I
would much because I if it came down to
it I would much rather freelance for the
rest of my life if I had that if I then
make something a week to week that I
couldn't really I don't know how to
articulate it but I just can't I can't I
can't create out of obligation I'm
incapable of it I think I mean I think I
totally understand and speaking speaking
as a fan I'm excited that there's gonna
be some more cons than yeah Channel two
very excited that you're going through
with this this movie idea because we've
always talked about it okay when is he
gonna do it when is he gonna when he's
gonna make this feature-length film that
I think is going in our minds will be
the feature-length film that they point
to as okay that's when the youtuber did
transition then did it right I mean
that's not to put the pressure on you or
anything she sets a lot that's you know
that's our expectation at this point so
it better be all I you know I I would
say that inaccurate and to sum up
everything we've just said you know I am
excited I'm genuinely excited about you
know re-engaging my audience and making
more things but that said my channel is
and always has been and always will be
you know subject to me making my first
feature film because that's why I
started it I started it to see if I
could make something people would
actually want to watch and now that I
know that
that I have an audience I am just
waiting till I have that idea finished
where I can go do it so everything I've
done and everything I continue to do
will be through the glass the goggles of
you know working towards making that
movie so it's all kind of up in the air
that's why I don't have any permanent
plans but I know I can say I will
definitely be making more content very
very soon well I can guarantee you that
uh everyone will be happy I will be very
easy it sounds like you were listening
to that voice and that's really what we
want or like I said as fans the best
thing we could want is for you to follow
the internal urge mmm
to create as Julian Smith settle your
biological clock I'm going compass I'm
gonna go to sleep and be a good father
so we can help with that and sign the
table because you know that's what time
it is it's time for you to take this
well you know you can open it do I sign
while we're recording sure thanks for
having me guys and that was our
conversation with the Julian Smith I
like talking to that guy you know I'm
glad to consider him a friend I consider
my creative genius hopefully I'd you
know I didn't I was Fanning out a little
bit that I was trying to just be honest
by the fact that I am a big fan and I
really admire his work and I also like
all these other people I want to see
more videos I was I was fanning out you
mean you were fangirling is that what
you want to say I use it no I use
Fanning out because it means you're
spreading yeah well because physically I
was like in it I was standing up in like
a jumping jack position the people can't
see a home no you weren't
but you were fangirling but he's
actually a friend of ours not really no
appropriate thanks girl that's what
someone who's a friend I'm a little
conflicted because he is a friend he was
actually a friend before I was really
that familiar with this work but I'm
saying that we often use him as a you
know or like well what would this look
like if Julian did it and so I love to
just sit there and pick his brain and
talk to him about what he's thinking and
I think it's interesting that we've
determined that if our standard is
Julian a lot of times in terms of how
good
something looks how something funny
something is his standard is women is on
mine you know I guess I mentioned
multiple times the voice in Julian said
and how he listens to the voice I don't
know if I mischaracterized him as crazy
like he listens to a voice in his own
head but you know I'm just saying that
he's a what's well I think you said
inner voice which inner voice is much
better than the voice in your head did
you actually say the voices in your play
that's it that's the litmus test if you
say the voices in your head and you use
plural
that's crazy person but if you just say
the voice your inner voice that's it
that's like a television show inner
artist yeah the inner voice is a new
spin-off of the voice that's coming out
well whatever I said whatever I said I'm
minute with the highest esteem and it
was a good conversation we gained
understanding those who were wanting to
know the answer to the question where
has he been you know hopefully you're
satisfied well that's what we try to do
here on air biscuits I mean we're having
a good time we're having a conversation
we're asking the questions that we want
the answers for but we hope that we are
in one in one sense sort of speaking on
your behalf asking questions on your
behalf we know that you want to know you
know what Julian is up to when his next
video is gonna come out what what he's
thinking about and hopefully this was
satisfactory on some level you enjoy the
biscuit and I similarly the right
consistency and the flavor was right
I like the on this gets undercooked a
little bit by the way like a light
biscuit a warm light biscuit for your
ears we do it every week and we thank
you for sharing the fact that we do this
with your friends bring them on in we
can handle it we made this for you
guys can I steal that can I say that
[Music]
[Music]